hey David says gone if we can't get
medicare-for-all what are ways that we
could improve the Affordable Care Act
this is so I want to deal with the
question because it's a good one but
it's also so politically loaded right
now because we're seeing this battle
among among the deli within the
Democratic Party I will remind you the
position of the Democratic Party
platform right now if you go to their
website is not Medicare for all it's not
eliminate private insurance it's not
universal health care it's not any of
that stuff
it is Medicare opt in at age 55 lower
the age at which you can opt in to
Medicare from 65 to 55 and a public
option that's the Democratic position
and what so we're seeing among
Democratic candidates is they are
needing to they are being forced to take
a position on Medicare for all they're
all paying lip service to it but some
are already kind of backing away we've
seen Connell Harris back away after
saying during a town hall Medicare for
all is the way we've seen cory booker
start to play a little coy with it we're
seeing others so i'll give you the full
list when we dive into that in depth and
so I want to address I will address the
question of how it if we don't have
Medicare for all how could we improve
the system we have or build on the
Affordable Care Act just remember that
this has become a very very toxic thing
related to the 2020 presidential
election it's being used by a lot of
people to play games and to try to have
it both ways and ride the fence in a way
that we really shouldn't allow them to
that being said how do we improve the
Affordable Care Act number one you've
got to put right back in the individual
health care mandate that Donald Trump
removed via his tax reform plan you've
got to do that that's how its
sustainable that I mean period and for
everybody who says well it's not really
free stuff if we're paying for it
through taxes yet no one is saying that
any of this stuff is free no one's
saying Medicare for all is free we did a
piece on Monday estimating that Medicare
for all would add about 1.2 trillion
dollars in costs per year the problem is
that we can't or not the problem the
great views is that we can more than pay
for that through means that have been
very specific
we researched an outlined and it would
be at a net savings to employers and
individual households a four percent tax
on households earning more than twenty
nine thousand dollars for example
considering that most households spend
between four and five thousand dollars a
year on premiums and co-pays it's gonna
save most households money right so just
because something has a cost it's like
okay but what are the savings so we
should absolutely put back in the
individual mandate you need that for the
system to function properly we should
add an actual public option okay they're
not I'm not talking about a state
subsidized option although that's good
and we've had that here in Massachusetts
for a long time I'm not talking about
really crappy cheap catastrophic only
plans that cover nothing but are just
there to meet the requirements of the
individual mandate I'm saying a genuine
public option and in addition to that we
also need to continue examining what is
going on with bureaucracy and
bureaucratic costs that's a huge driver
of costs in American in the American
healthcare industry and then you can
start looking at you know all sorts of
other things we should be negotiating on
drugs there's no reason why Americans
through insurance that is mostly coming
through employers should be paying
outrageous costs for medications that go
for a fraction of the cost in other
countries it's a very very long list but
public option and putting the individual
mandate back in would be near the top of
that list but I I just reject on
principle that there's something
untenable about actually figuring out
how to get a universal health care
single-payer medicare-for-all some
version of that which every other
country at our level of development has
been able to do